>> Laura: WE'LL SEE.
WHO KNOWS WHAT MIGHT HAPPEN WITH
ANGELA AFTER THIS EVENT.
WE JUST DON'T KNOW WHAT WILL
HAPPEN.
ED, THANKS SO MUCH.
NOW FOR TONIGHT ANGLE.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION TAKES
THE CARAVAN TO COURT.
NO DOUBT YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT THE
CARAVAN OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
MOVING NORTH THROUGH MEXICO.
ACCORDING TO
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" COME OVER
100 HAVE ALREADY MADE IT TO THE
U.S. BORDER.
THE CARAVAN STARTED OUT WITH
MORE THAN 1,000 PEOPLE.
IT IS NOW DOWN TO ABOUT 500 OR
SO.
NOW, SOME OF THESE MIGRANTS HAVE
TOLD REPORTERS THAT THEY PLANNED
TO FIND WAYS TO GET ACROSS THE
U.S. BORDER.
NOW, MOST OF THEM ARE FROM
HONDURAS, SO MANY ARE EXPECTED
TO APPLY FOR ASYLUM SUPPOSEDLY
TO ESCAPE VIOLENCE AT HOME.
WELL, ANTICIPATING BACKUP ON THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS SENDING
ADDITIONAL I.C.E. ATTORNEYS,
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT JUDGES, AND
ALSO PROSECUTORS TO MAKE SURE
THE CARAVAN ASYLUM CASES WILL BE
"ADJUDICATED PROPERLY."
WE HAVE ALSO LEARNED, THIS IS
CURIOUS, THAT AMERICAN ATTORNEYS
HAVE TRAVELED SOUTHWARD TO MEET
WITH MIGRANTS TO INSTRUCT THEM
ON THEIR RIGHTS TO APPLY FOR
ASYLUM HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES.
WE DID SOME DIGGING, AND
ACCORDING TO REPORTS, TWO OF
THESE LAWYERS ARE ALLEGRA LOVE
OF SANTA FE DREAMERS PROJECT,
AND MARIE VINCENT, WHO ALSO
WORKS FOR A SMALL 5O1C3
ORGANIZATION.
VINCENT HAS SAID THAT MANY OF
THE MIGRANTS ARE STRONG
CANDIDATES FOR ASYLUM BECAUSE
THEY ARE FLEEING POLITICAL
PERSECUTION OR VIOLENT GAMES
WERE THREATS OVER THEIR GENDER
OR SEXUAL ORIENTATION.
BUT FOR ASYLUM ELIGIBILITY,
ACCORDING TO SECTION 1208 OF THE
TITLE 8 CODE, ATTORNEYS HAVE TO
ESTABLISH THAT THEIR CLIENT HAS
"REASONABLE FEAR OF
PERSECUTION."
AND THAT IS WHAT DEMOCRATS AND
THE MEDIA HAVE BEEN CLAIMING,
THAT THESE ARE POLITICAL
REFUGEES ESCAPING VIOLENCE AND
THE ESKIMO PERSECUTION.
>> IT'S REALLY MORE OF A
SYMBOLIC KIND OF P.R. MOVED BY
THE MIGRANTS WHO WANT TO TALK
ABOUT AND WANT TO BRING LIGHT TO
THE LACK OF RULE OF LAW AND THE
HUMAN RIGHTS VIOLATIONS THAT
OCCUR IN CENTRAL AMERICA.
>> EVERY TIME THE PRESIDENT GETS
IN A POLITICAL JAM, ANYTIME HE
IS FEELING THREATENED
POLITICALLY, HE GOES BACK TO A
FEW OF THE SAME THINGS.
BEATING UP ON IMMIGRANTS,
MEXICANS OR CRIMINALS.
>> THE PICTURE OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP PAINTS HORDES OF
IMMIGRANTS, MANY OF THEM
CRIMINALS POISED TO STORM THE
BORDER BUT THE CARAVAN CNN
FOUND IS A VERY DIFFERENT
SCENARIO.
WE WILL TAKE YOU LIVE TO MEET
THE FAMILIES.
MANY WOMEN AND CHILDREN WAITING
FOR THE NEXT MOVE.
>> Laura: WELL, THERE ARE NEXT
IS TO CRASH INTO OUR COUNTRY
COUNTRY.
THE PROBLEM FOR THE ATTORNEYS
HELPING THE MEMBERS OF THE
CARAVAN COULD BE THE U.S. LAW,
THE CODE SECTION 12 -- 1324,
EXCUSE ME OF TITLE 8.
AN OFFENSE FOR ANY PERSON WHO
ENCOURAGES OR INDUCE AND ALIEN
TO COME TO, ENTER, OR RESIDE
IN THE UNITED STATES KNOWING OR
IN RECKLESS DISREGARD OF THE
FACT THAT STENCH COMING TO, ENTR
YOUR RESIDENCE IS OR WILL BE IN
VIOLATION OF LAW.
THE QUESTION IS WHEN DOES
ADVOCACY FOR ILLEGALS AND UP
CROSSING THE LINE TO COMMITTING
A 1324 OFFENSE.
INTERESTING LEGAL QUESTION.
WELL, BECAUSE OF THE
ATTORNEY-CLIENT PRIVILEGE, THIS
COULD BE TOUGH TO DETERMINE.
BUT AS THESE ATTORNEYS ARE
HOLDING WHAT IS BEING DESCRIBED
AS THESE LARGE GROUP SEMINARS
AND DEMONSTRATE INTENT TO SKIRT
THE LAWS OR TO HELP THE MIGRANT
SKIRT THE LAWS, WELL, THEY COULD
BE IN JEOPARDY AT LEAST
TECHNICALLY.
HERE'S THE OTHER PROBLEM FOR
THESE LAWYERS.
MOST OF THE PEOPLE IN THIS
CARAVAN, AS I SAID, ARE FROM
HONDURAS.